thank you very much for the introduction
and by the way gareth told me a lot
about eindhoven which i've never been
and i look forward to visiting sometime
after this whole pandemic thing is over
so data driven decisions is now common
practice in many companies
around the world but one looming
question that's kind of
challenging is how do you make the best
decision when you want to optimize not
for one
objective but more
the reason this is an interesting
question is because many uh
objectives are in conflict and that
results in trade-off decision making
for example even when we do shopping
right we constantly compare
price versus quality it's hard to both
minimize the price while maximizing
quality and this is relevant for many
industries
for example um supply chain uh chain
management manufacturing
land use planning and also of course in
the very timely
drug discovery um in which
for in this example if we want to
consider a candidate
antibody to be a therapeutic that will
that will cure us
it has to pass many tests and it takes
only one test
for it to fail and um nowadays we hear
about
therapeutics uh for covert ib being
available
uh uh researched and brought to to
production within the year
it normally takes 10 or 12 years and so
imagine a project
of discovering that something fails
after such a long walk
and one way to solve for this is the
topic of
this discussion it's called
multi-objective optimization
and these are the four main
ideas that i will be circulating around
and and
i want you to take home with you uh well
first i'm going to talk about the
shortcomings
of what's called single objective
optimization and that's basically the
common practice of what most analysts do
when they're dealing with
two or more uh parameters that they're
interested in optimizing over
you're all familiar with it in which we
combine it in some way or form
and then we optimize over that single
heuristic and so i'll point out why
that's a very limited approach and it
yields
sub-optimal results and how we can fix
this with a technique
called pareto front and then i'll
introduce how we can actually use
greater fronts in the context of genetic
algorithms i'm not assuming that
anybody knows what a genetic algorithm
is i'll explain it
from scratch and then i'll talk about
applicability
in the real world uh as we've learned
from the previous talk how important
that issue is and the main thing that i
hope that you take home with you
is understanding the technique enough in
its principles
to be able to assess for yourself
if this technique is relevant for the
project that you're working on
so this is just a brief description of
what i've been up to in the past
uh 16 years or so i'm currently a data
scientist in a healthcare company
i started off as an academic doing
research in observational cosmology
and most relevant for this talk i spent
two years in a biotech company
called lab genius in which we're
applying machine learning for
therapeutic discovery
uh and on this note i want to mention
that uh pi data has been part of my
trajectory as of about
2014 when i came to london so this is uh
the place to thank all
the uh um organizers here
in eindhoven and especially uh the ones
in london that helped me like
uh create a place where i could share
our ideas and learn more
more about uh what it's like to
transition from academia
to the private sector um
so this is a list of topics that i want
to go through um
it seems kind of daunting but don't
worry i'll break it down and hopefully
you'll have
appreciation uh from for most of what
i'm going to talk about today
um so with that let's i'll define um how
i'm going to use the term
optimization in this talk uh i define it
as a procedure of finding and comparing
feasible solutions until no better can
be found
you know a topic is interesting if
randall monroe the creator of xkcd
has a comic strip about it so i like
this one in particular
in which he subject subjectively
distributes fruit according to his
preference
both in taste where you can see uh he
finds the most taste he wants to be
in his peaches and uh
and according to how easy it is to eat
then he ranks seedless grapes as the
most optimal so my question for the
audience and i'll give you just a few
seconds to think about it which is the
optimal fruit
that you as his let's say his office
mate would bring from the kitchen
if you want to optimize for both taste
and how easy it is to eat
so just think about it no need to put in
your answers
all right so um you might have said
peaches you might have said seedless
grapes some of you might have said
strawberries
so the answer is that it was actually a
trick question
there's no one optimal fruit but
actually throughout this talk what
you'll appreciate is that
these three are considered equally
optimal and
uh hello el are you there i think we
lost you for a second
so uh we're we're we're gonna bring you
back online
very good hi can you hear me yes yes so
we lost you at the optimal
uh front so at the optimal fruit
fruit decision front oh
and i and you didn't hear the answer
that i gave to that uh you said you just
presented the slide that there's a front
right so maybe take it from there again
if you don't mind so you asked the
question
and the slide appeared and then we lost
your voice
okay uh yeah i think my internet dropped
some reason so i i showed you that
there's an optimal front
that's what i showed right
i think you need to hear your screen yes
there it is okay very good
okay so just to recap i showed um
yeah so i showed that there's this
optimal front and what um
and the per the purpose of this talk is
for you to appreciate
why these are considered equally optimal
and um
what we can actually do with that sort
of definition
um so just before we get into that let's
take i'll take a step back and we'll
explore what you were doing mentally in
your mind and as
analysts what we do in our everyday when
we want to optimize
for multiple objectives uh and these
objectives
here i give them boring labels as one
and two uh
but think of it as price versus quality
or if you're
doing hyperparameter tuning of uh in
machine learning then imagine these as
being hyper parameters that you want
optimizer
so what you want to imagine is that you
you're in a dark room with a flashlight
and and you're using this flashlight in
order to explore directions
that you're most interested in and so
whatever a lot of
a lot of us do is what we call single
objective optimization
so what does that mean is that we come
up with some ad hoc uh
combination of both objectives and then
we will bore
a tunnel in our search space so for
example here we'll dig we'll do we'll
dig
we see there's no solutions over here
and so this is the
most optimal solution and we'll tag that
and we'll say that's optimal
and then we'll make decisions based on
that
uh of course i did multiplication but
can do other things
like you can do the mean and these are
cases for max max imagine you can do max
min
and then you'll divide etc but at the
end of the day all these are the same
you're getting you're you're you're
taking all your parameters
and you're combining them into one
single heuristic
uh and so this approach is very limited
here i'll show you another
another approach of this is uh and this
is what's done
in in some laboratories in which they
optimize for one parameter
and then they are optimized for the
other parameter and so in this method
they'll say hey
this data point is uh we'll consider it
optimal but they could just as likely
started with objective two
and then go to objective one and say
this one and so you're already noticing
that something very weird is going here
i made three uh subjective decisions of
how i want to explore the space and i
got three totally different
uh optimal solutions and so
in multi-objective optimization what we
say is that we want to actually turn on
the light
we want to see the full solution space
and then we want to make our subjective
decision of what we consider
optimal for example here we want to
maximize both of these so
we want to get over here but there's no
feasible solution remember we talked
about only feasible solutions
and so maybe our domain expert which
might be ourself
or somebody uh um who actually knows
more about these parameters will select
let's say this one
or maybe they want to consider more
overweighting objective two than
objective one and they'll select maybe
uh this one over here or another one so
how do we quantify this in a more
rigorous way well what we'd say
is that we have this uh we'll have this
front called the pareto front of
solutions
in which they are all considered equally
optimal
and once we realize that then we'll make
our subjective decision
so more about that later um
so what i've defined so far is the
limitations of single objective
optimization it gave us a limited view
of our search space
with pareto front we'll be able to
explore the full solution space to make
better decisions
but just before i define what a pareto
front is uh you notice i use the word
uh subjectivity a few times so far
and that's on purpose i was dripping it
into your mind
that as an analyst i try my best to be
as objective as possible in every step
along the way of my process
but i have to be at the end of the day
humble and realize and identify where i
make subjective
decisions so in the case of single
objective optimization
or that linear approach that i described
before this
we're making subjective decisions before
we even starting the search
but the purpose of multi-objective
optimization is holding on to that
not making that decision and and and
and applying subjectivity only after we
finish this the search
so with that in mind now i'm ready to
define what a pareto front is
so if we're looking at solutions then we
can divide them into two
we have what's called a dominated here
highlighted in gray and then we have the
non-dominated highlighted here in red
and the set of all the non-dominated are
called the pareto front and their uni
and their nice property is that because
we haven't applied subjectivity we
we consider them all equally optimal
so just to guide you how how do you
quickly identify
uh the dominated from the non-dominant
for example focus on k over here
so k is dominated by by d for example
and the reason for that is that
a solution is dominated if we can find
another solution
that dominates it that has a better
value
in all of the objectives this is of
course 2d and you can
extrapolate this to higher dimension but
here you can see dominant
d dominates k both in objective 1 and
objective two
same thing for e as opposed to what as
opposed to c
for example c is dominated by d in
objective one
but not in objective two here of course
i'm assuming that we wanna maximize for
both one and two
the same but opposite between c and b we
can see that b
dominates c in objective two but not in
objective one
and and so this applies for c and as
well as all of these that are lettered
from a to h
another interesting aspect of this is
that we do not care
about the relationship of units or
scales between objective one and
objective two
again remember this could be price
versus quality so you don't have to put
monetary value on quality or hyper
parameters which have totally different
scales totally different units
so this naturally is agnostic to this
and so i know that you're looking at
this and you want to say oh but these
d is the most optimal at the end of the
day yes we're going to apply a
subjectivity but that's only after we
get the full snapshot
of the solution space so once we have
this then we can make our subjective
decision
which way we want to go do we want to go
to d we want to go to h
or any combination depending on how many
solutions we can make in our decision
depending on the context
so what i've described so far is um i
introduced to you pareto front
as a set of trade-off non-dominant
solutions
and the reason that we could define this
is that we um did not make our
subjective decision
before going to search but rather we
were holding this until after the search
and what this means is that uh at the uh
the advantage of this approach of
multi-objective optimization
versus the single objective optimization
is
where now we get like a bird's-eye view
of the full solution space
and we can make better decisions as
opposed to before what i showed you is
that we were effectively
putting on horse blinders and that was
guiding us to
one solution or another that we called
optimal but we saw that
that that um that we might have
preferred something else
if we had a bird's-eye view
so just a quick question you know so
yeah the question that came through is
that
can you maybe share a few practical
examples of where in your experience
you've kind of
used this and i think you'll be talking
a little bit about later but um
just to kind of ground us to where this
is used
and where you've used it personally can
you share a few words on that yeah
yeah that actually that will be the the
lion's share of my thought
um let me just think yeah so i'm going
to get into genetic algorithms
yeah so i applied it within the context
of therapeutic discovery
in which i showed before you have a
antibody
in which um you have many candidate uh
proteins called antibodies and they have
to pass many tests
and i was testing it for um for for two
parameters
of interest you can imagine something
like um response of the immune system
and potency for example and um it's a
way
to um i had a machine learning model
that given a sequence of antibodies i
could predict
um those parameters and that way i could
suggest
so once we have the machine learning
model i could propose
to a protein engineer who orders
uh those sequences which which sequences
to order
um if that didn't make any sense well
i'm going to go back to that later but
that's just to
write your appetite for for where i
personally have applied it and i'll show
this also later on in this case study
in terms of you can use it for
hyperparameter tuning
okay very cool thank you yeah um
so yeah so uh now i wanted to
now that you have a basic understanding
of what pareto fronts are
i want you to have a feeling for is this
relevant for the projects you're working
on
and just before i do that we have to
understand the parameters
that we have and a useful splitting
between
decision space to objective space so
objective space
is what we've been i've been describing
so far those that's what we're actually
interested in that that's um
uh that's what we want from our system
so that uh you can imagine that
that's being the quality or that's being
the price of the project
where decision space is what we actually
have control over
so just to give you um two examples um
of this
is for example there's the classical
problem called the knapsack
problem in which what you have is you
have uh
you have uh packages and each one has a
monetary value
and it has a weight and you pack these
packages
in the knapsack and what you want to do
is you want to optimize
both you want to optimize uh where you
want to maximize the value
of the package that you select but you
also want to minimize their
their weight and so those are two
objectives there are obviously
right the more packages you put in the
more weight it's going to gain
uh and so what do we have control over
what's our decision space for our
decision space is which subsets of
packages
do we choose and then our objective
space is
uh the the calculated weight or the
calculated value
and these arrows are important because
that shows that we have
uh we we we have a a function
that goes from the decision space to the
objective space
another example is hyper parameter
tuning right
we're not actually interested in the
hyper parameters but that's what we have
control over
what we're interested in at the end of
the day is metrics
for example precision recall accuracy
depending
on on on on the application that you're
working on
and another important factor is the
mapping between them right if we change
the hyper parameters
in order to get the metrics well we have
these pipelines we have the training
and the testing of our data and so this
this might be a function of time which
might be crucial
so what i'm trying to say is um is
multi-objective is multi-objective
optimization relevant for your project
well of course it depends
and it depends on first of all that you
have full control over your decision
space
if you have control over your decision
states for example the hyper parameters
and the model you want to do
the second thing is you need an
inexpensive mapping
from your decision space to your
objective space for example
a counter example of that is let's say
um you're a marketing firm
and you have to make decisions between
uh approach a
b c or d and um
and and the metrics of interest uh let's
say click rate or anything like that
let's say that's a oh that's a function
that will take time in order for you to
get like you have to put into the field
it will take a few days
until you get the feedback so that's
that's would be like expensive feedback
so
then it might not be relevant for you
but that said if you have this as a
space and you have
some sort of model if it's deterministic
or probabilistic to get to the
objectives you're interested in
uh then then you're golden then you're
good to go
um if this is something that uh if you
can brute force your way to the full
solution space
then you can literally open up an excel
spreadsheet you can draw
a pareto pareto front uh sit with the
domain expert
who may actually make the decisions and
choose which solutions you want to
go go forward with most likely though
you're going to deal with an intractable
search space
so that means you won't be able to force
your way to all the solutions but you'll
be able to get some sort of proxy
of what the solution space from your
bird's eye view
actually looks like and in that case you
will want to use a stochastic algorithm
that's intelligent in the way that it
navigates through
the solution space uh so one
that practitioners like to use is called
genetic algorithms
i'm sure that you heard the name i'm not
assuming that you know
how this works so i'll describe it for
those who do
i'll get i will point out where pareto
optimization actually goes
into this calculation because a lot of
people use genetic algorithms but they
do it with single objective optimization
not realizing the power of pareto fronts
and that's one of the objectives of this
topic
so uh genetic algorithms are great to
use for when you're dealing with
intractable com
combinatorial space one reason is that
you can
get multiple solutions right in pareto
front we want
multiple solutions we don't want to uh
we
don't want to end up just with one and
also um
you have you can apply techniques like
niching that means that you don't get
into
let's say uh um in into like a local
minimum or something like that
and so you can apply uh like send your
send your population to
many regions uh so we have this
algorithm for about 60 years now
and it's based on evolution uh in which
uh our population our solutions are
considered a population
which we have that individuals within
the populations compete with
between them and we have them passing on
their traits to the next generations
um through their children uh and at
night this is a nice way to summarize it
explore as much as you can
and keep the best there are various
uh this is one type of art architecture
and so i'll just guide you through this
so you have a basic intuition
for genetic uh how a genetic algorithm
actually works
so you start off with an initial
population
so uh no need of knowledge in biology
here but this is a representation of
proteins so this is
in relevant to the work that that case
study that i'll show later on
in which this is a sequence in which uh
in
white we have uh so each letter sorry
represents
a chemical compound called uh an amino
acid
and so there are about 20 in nature and
so in white are the ones that we're
holding fixed
what biologists called wild or we
consider them as the vanilla
and in red are the mutations that we're
inducing
um let's find out the things in terms of
biology there's uh
actually the knapsack problem is a
perfect analogy in which uh
the whole like what whatever this is
over here uh 15 or 20
is is or 10 actually is um
amino acids uh is the full knapsack and
each each position here
is a different package and so each
letter represents a different package
you can change
or imagine this as you have 10 hyper
parameters and each letter
represents a value each position is a
different hyperparameter and each letter
is a different value okay so all these
are perfect analogies for what i'm going
to describe
uh keep a mental picture of whatever you
prefer
okay so we start with the initial
population uh and this is our decision
space this is what we have control over
uh for example i worked with um
with protein engineers and they
literally they can manipulate these
amino acids which is pretty far out
um but that's not where what we're
interested in at the end of the day
um as the analysts we're interested in
the objective space right um
for example um potency and reaction to
the immune system for example
uh and so for each solution uh we have
both of these values and we can put them
in a plot like this and
by now your eye is kind of let's say i
want to maximize objective one and
objective two
by now your eyes already kind of looking
hopefully
towards the optimal set of
equally optimal solutions otherwise
known as a pareto front
and of course that's this envelope over
here so these are the ones in a very
naive
selection function are going to be
selected for the next generation and
then we do some
we do transformations in order to get um
similar results for uh similar
uh um solutions uh converting them
from parents to children so we have
something called uh crossover which is
similar to what happens
with with our chromosomes in which uh we
have one from each parent
and then we have mixing of the
information between them so here we just
have a crossover
so child one has half this half compared
one
and this half from parent two and vice
versa for the second child
another transformation we can do is we
can convert one
amino acid to another one or in the case
of the knapsack problem just change
one package for another package and so
we'll do this with in many
iterations and we can let's say stop
after 40 or 100 iterations
and at the end of this process what
we'll have we'll have a list of
all the um other individual
sequences that we that we examined and
we'll have
all of these scores so what we get at
the end is a list of our decision space
that we have full control over and our
objective space what we actually
want uh so now what i'll show you is an
animation
of uh going through many iterations of
this just so you see
how this evolves with time and here i'm
actually going to start with the
non-realistic example in which
both objective 1 and objective 2 this is
being minimized and so
we want to get the x in which they
actually agree
so here you see some here you see this
is a pareto front of actually one
and uh this is an animation which i'll
start and you'll see them going all the
way over here
more realistically is if they are on
conf and so here the votes we want to
maximize for both and here
and so we want to get to the x this is
like a classical looking
uh pareto front and which it starts over
here um
again blue is the pareto front uh
the gray are the dominated and now what
you'll see is you'll see this this
pareto front like
approaching x but never really reaching
there so let's say i start
from over here
and you can see the envelope moved
forward with
large jumps at the beginning but then a
little bit by bit it's improving
uh um we saw an improvement
okay so what i what i showed you right
now is that uh
in most of real life uh scenarios you're
gonna have to deal with intractable
spaces
and so you'll want a smart statistic uh
search mechanism to navigate through it
and i show a genetic algorithm as one
option in order to exploit the space
and the reason is it works naturally
with pareto fronts uh which come into
its selection function
and now i'll talk about real world
applications so let's say
um that you have um
you realize that you have everything
that's required you have your decision
you have full control over this is in
space you have in
you have an inexpensive mapping to your
uh
objective space and let's say you have
an attractable search space so you
decide to go with genetic algorithms and
i suggest uh for
prototyping purposes in python this this
module called d uh this is that yes this
is with a
because it's uh evolutionary algorithms
in its acronym
and it's very simple to use and you can
paralyze
during search and it has a very uh
simple ap
a fairly simple api to use and which
what what we can see here the snippet of
my code in which i'm feeding custom made
functions
for example make new plate into the
toolbox registry
and so the nice thing is that i don't
have to uh
script for myself pareto fronts i
described something very simplistic
before
actually and what they have is the
frontline algorithms um
and so this one for example by name is
called its acronym is
spea2 and so they have this
all built in and so if you want to take
this on i highly recommend this
um module now i'll talk about uh a
case study something that i actually
worked on uh in my
previous job and so i worked in lab
genius which is
a biotech company which have their own
lab
and what they're doing they're
generating their own data in order to
use machine learning
to discover uh therapeutics their focus
is on crohn's disease
uh in this case study i'm actually using
publicly available data
so so not their data uh but just to
showcase
like the capabilities of what we're
building there
so the data at large is um is antibodies
that are scored for binding and i also
model them
for um something i'll call potency um
those details don't matter uh what is
interesting is that
of a length 200 there were 20 places
that were mutated
so here i just combine all those
positions together just for simplicity
and what you can see here oh by the way
so each position can have 20
combinations
20 to the power 20 is 10 to the power 26
so that's intractable that's why i use
genetic algorithms
uh so what you can see here is that it's
highly skewed towards
the um the wild type again so what you
can see here dominating
is um sorry it is the wild type sequence
and then you can see 10 of these what's
squished over here are the different
amino acids that they
tried mutating uh within their data set
so what we had
is a machine running out yes that's a
question from the audience
sure so uh thinking uh going a little
bit back to your previous slide about an
abstract problem
he's saying i'm thinking about
formulating a knapsack problem
in the context of gas the knapsack
places a constraint on the genes
not all crossover or mutations will
result in feasible solutions
how would you account this for a genetic
algorithm
sorry repeat the question so there's
some kind of
constraint on an abstract problem so
not all crossovers or mutation real
result and feasible solutions
i suppose depends on how you design your
genes right
but how how would this work for
something like the knapsack problem
yeah yeah so um oh the question is for
the knapsack whether
i mean so first i can answer for biology
like there are like infeasible solutions
there are combinations
uh that aren't feasible so that's
something that you can uh remember
that in in deep i showed that i could do
like custom functions and so i can take
all those real-life scenarios into
accounts uh
and so what that means is i can um
so if i'm maximizing for example then i
can give a very low
value for example for that or i can do
like or i can introduce like cutoffs
in my algorithm uh and in the knapsack
um uh ask me again at the end if it
wasn't clear
and i'll address that as well i think
it's clear so in your algorithm it's
yeah he's saying that sufficiently
answers
my question oh yes so basically you can
just kick out the bit
jeans or have a very low score for them
so they won't be crossover
right yeah yeah so anything that's
unvisible that then you
you can um dictate that yeah
okay thanks so uh what we have basically
is a machine learning model
in which given a sequence we can predict
for binding and potency
but what i want to do is i don't want to
give the protein biologists machine
learning model i want to give them
actual sequences
and so what my task is to do is to use
the machine learning model as my comp is
to navigate the solution space in order
to climb the hill
as much as possible to give the
sequences that are most likely
to succeed in our objectives
so that's the task at hand and so what
i'm showing you here is animation
of of uh the genetic algorithm of what's
happening in our decision space again
what we have control over so i'll just
rewind the video
it's not working there so here i'm
starting at iteration zero so whereas
before i show the frequency of the amino
acids here i'm showing the change in
in frequency so the way to read that is
that if t
was 90 at the beginning now it's at
about minus 50
so it's actually like 40 but i'm just
highlighting here on the bottom that's
much less than what it is in the data
uh and then you can see like the
competition between the the
wild type t to all the other amino acids
and so with time you can see that um
for example over here the wild type w
is it is rejected and it prefers
actually
a in this position but another position
actually it's fine with the wild type
there's no other preference
for for any other amino acid so that's
something
so that way uh it's a way for me to
visualize like what's happening in the
decision space
but of course we're interested in the
objective space right these are
like the potency and binding and immune
response etc
uh so it started off over here and you
can sit and you start like
a jump over here and like slowly it's
pushing this envelope
more and more so towards uh this
direction over here
by the way all these but all these
visuals are made with matplotlib
if i can ask a question so to get this
yeah burrito
from so you mentioned the algorithm
that's inside the package right but i
suppose it is some kind of smoothing
around the burrito front
right because otherwise it's i mean
um do you know what it means how does
this
work more or less no there's no
requirement of
smoothing of the function so he's
referring to the fact that it looks kind
of rigid
um and that's totally fine because what
we're doing is we're selecting
individuals rather than creating
a continuous function does that answer
the question
so this is this is all discrete there's
there's nothing continuous over here
so just to make sure i understand that
maybe i missed this yeah so excuse my
ignorance here
when you talk about the pareto front
it's not that you're looking for a
mathematical equation
independently which dimension you're
looking at to describe that character
from
what you're really looking towards is
discretely visualize what that would
look like right
you know you have kind of like a cut off
front but you're not looking to
create a spline or something like that
to describe it
like literally like you see this over
here i'm literally like selecting that
the fact that it has an x on it that
means it's being selected for the next
generation
i'm selecting this solution right
right and the fact that our mind see
that that makes a lie
is just a that's what our minds see it
doesn't mean that that's what you're
effectively doing right so so in this
example
it feels very natural to draw a line
there
yeah that's an excellent point no but in
this animation wherever you see an x
that means i'm selecting that
particular solution for the next
generation
yes take the top place some kind of yeah
the top ones and then you do them all
across the line um yeah
i see but you just i mean um
what i meant with smoothing you do need
to
um okay never mind
or maybe let's continue and maybe
rephrase my question afterwards
yeah no i admit that discussions can be
quite abstract
but um yeah okay so we're nearly there
uh i just want to mention another case
study so um
yeah so i i was wondering like how many
people actually using this for the paint
for for uh for hyper parameter tuning as
as a use case uh because there again we
have multiple objectives that we're
looking to optimize from
and so sure enough i found this study by
uh
data scientists in sas in which they uh
worked with various uh clients of theirs
and so here i'm just highlighting
uh one of their projects with an
organization
called um donorschoose in which
they provide a platform for teachers to
request for uh um
material materials for projects that
they're working on and their challenge
is that they were overwhelmed with how
many
requests they have uh for review in
which over six hundred thousand about
twenty percent
uh they they considered are worthy for
review and so they wanted to automate
that
and one of the main objectives that they
wanted is they wanted
to reduce their false uh positive rate
so they want both misclassification but
mostly like reduce
the false positive uh and so
yeah so so here you have the link to the
actual study i won't get too much into
detail i'll just point out
like this nice result that um that they
show
and which what you can see here is um
so what they started off is they had
their vanilla machine learning algorithm
uh here um this black dot called default
and so this is what they have about
fifteen percent misclassification
and just south of four percent in fpr
and so they wouldn't want to minimize
both and so first they start with the
single objective
optimization that's your familiar f1 uh
um auc
and so you could remember i talked about
boring to to to
a certain direction and that's exactly
what it's doing you can see the single
objective of
single objective heuristics like going
like over here like reducing this
classification but actually
uh um doing worse in terms of fpr
so what they decide to do is well
they'll apply the pareto
front approach and what that's what you
see here with all these dots in which
the green
uh highlights the pareto front itself
and then
so note that with with f1 they made a
subjective decision before the search
but now that we're going to make a
subjective decision after the search so
they said well we don't like this cut
off this funky region here at
this very you know the steep thing over
here at 15 so they ran it again
this is a zoom this is a zoomed in
version in which they ran it again
in which they constrained their search
space to under
fifth uh uh um 15 so to answer the
question from before
about what you could see the feasible
they said but we don't consider anything
about
15 which was our vanilla that's feasible
we want anything below and so what you
can see here is these triangles
are performing slightly better than the
green but the most important thing
is they they feel they made a better
decision instead of
compromising on the standard single
objective optimization approach and
being over here
right their starting point was way over
here they actually went down here
and so their final result was that they
they improved
the fpr um you know by about a relative
eight percent
and they reduced uh the
misclassification by an absolute
five percent from fifteen percent down
to ten percent
and so i think that that's uh it's
encouraging to see that data scientists
are starting to apply this
in the context of multi-optimization but
they are
the um they're very few of them so
that's why i'm i like to promote this so
people including myself will start
doing um so that's it i just want to
mention that if anybody's interested in
learning more about
this i actually have a hands-on tutorial
that i posted
on github in which uh it comes with 30
minutes of
basically similar content that what i
presented here as well as
one hour in which i go through the
tutorials i have jupiter notebooks
uh in which you can clone or you can use
in in in collab
i'll very briefly show here it is
the um in github
so you have all the links to um the
videos and then you have links to
tutorials
so here's one it's uh the notebooks are
fully annotated
uh and i challenge you with questions so
just to see how much you're
understanding uh so
yeah so if if you're interested in this
topic then that uh
please consider as a resource um here
i'm providing
more research more resources for
anybody's interested
in learning more about the topic and the
most important takeaway
is this relevant for what you're working
on can you actually apply this
so uh you should apply this if you have
um more than one objective that are in
conflict
you have full control over your decision
space and you have an inexpensive
mapping
from your decision space to objective
space most likely you're going to deal
with intractable search space
in that case i suggest using genetic
algorithms and if you want to use python
then i suggest using
deep as a prototyping tool
so with that i'll just mention also one
more lesson from preparing for this talk
um my personal computer actually crashed
yesterday
that's what you're seeing over here so
my takeaway is very good
to have a backup let's say in google
drive of your talk
when you're preparing for a talk um so
yeah so with that i'm glad to take
any questions either here or in on the
okay island that's a very great lesson
takeaway lesson
always have a backup but um
so maybe i can rephrase my question a
bit so how
um okay so we can look at this figure as
an example right
um so basically how you make the
frontier
okay so there's some kind of a function
right maybe
one axis plus the other axis whatever
score is there
and then you take the for your genetic
algorithm you take the top
fixed amount of them for for your next
generation and that's how you
build the boundary or so so i look at i
look at the full solution space
so you're asking me how do i select the
population for the next generation
is that the question yes and how what's
your function basically to
uh to compare both skills
maybe more or less because there needs
it needs to come together at some point
to do your selection right
you mean between the decision space and
the objective space
yeah so if you have a if you select your
next generation that might be
one completely uh would do very well on
one axis
and very well on the other so how do you
balance between those right i mean
there's some kind of skills skill in
there that you you need to
yeah okay so so okay so so
this is going more into detail about um
such a question
um something i have discussed so and
it's something that i go
in into uh into fair detail within the
tutorials
um so when you go from one
generation to another you have to define
parameters for example
how many uh solutions do you want to go
to the next generation so let's say you
start off
with a population of 20 and then based
on that 20 you create let's say another
um 40 or or or or 60 more children so
let's say
you have um a population that's
competing for the next generation
of let's say 100 solutions and you have
to select 20.
okay so then you have three options
either you have a pareto front
right you identify the pareto front and
let's say you count exactly 20
okay then a simple algorithm will say
okay let's just choose all the 20. i
don't care how ridiculous
it is let's say the ones over here i
don't care that it's very low
we we have we're not making any
subjective decisions
we're holding that urge um
because i can hear it in your question
like oh this is doing really bad right
but i don't know i don't know the scales
yet i haven't determined that i'm a
gnostic
so i don't know how bad being over here
is because i have i'm not i haven't made
that decision yet
um so so that's the case in which i
i predefined uh i want to select out of
100
i want to select 20 for the next
generation my pareto fund happens to be
exactly 20. then i'm golden
well what if let's say my protofront is
20 but i told it
let's say i decide i want to take 20 but
i actually have only 19
on my pareto front so that means well
i'm taking my whole parade up front of
19
but then i have to choose another one
from the next layer
so i take out the pareto front and then
i select the next layer of pareto font
for my solution space so
um
so let's say let's say i selected all of
these okay
let's say these are um this is what one
two
this is let's say eight let's say my i
decided i want ten
well these are all selected but then i
have the next pareto front which
comprises this one this one
this one and this one so out of these i
have to choose two
okay and so there's a simplistic way to
go up there's a simplistic way
to go about it but then there's the
state of the art so that's what i
mentioned in deep they have like
state-of-the-art algorithms and i give
references
so you can learn about how to go about
choosing them so the state of the art
what they do
is they look at the density of solutions
so they
account for the density so if they're
two solutions in a dense region we'll
select one of them as opposed to two of
them
and also they um some of some of the
algorithms to maintain like the edge
cases because they are interested
in diversifying that's one class that i
didn't talk about
in this and i do in the tutorials is the
importance of diversity
yes exactly yeah that's yeah let's touch
upon my question because you can see
them well spread around the
the front right but that doesn't really
happen automatically i would believe
that yeah
yeah so so maybe i should yeah i could
have made my answer much shorter but
just emphasizing that the
diversity is the key aspect for uh
for for genetic algorithms it was a bit
of an open question so
and you explain a lot of things so i
have another question from jessica
have you seen pareto optimization in
combination with other algorithms
instead of
genetic algorithms any good pro con
takeaways
have i seen a good question um
[Music]
so so i mean it can work with any
uh not any stochastic um
nothing comes to my mind at the most um
most of
most of my uh exploration of the topic
when i went to literature
uh most of the experts talk about
genetic algorithms but
there might be others but i i'm not
aware of it
yeah okay and just get i think pretty
much the same question as i have
because she now says i think you just
answered my second question also
so that's that's great yeah but it's an
interesting question whether it works
with other algorithms but
i think so what's happening with the
preset from this is some kind of an
or statement going on right because
you're looking for both
either uh it could be one option in your
so
i think with other methods it would be a
little bit tricky because you
would more or less still need to
translate it into some kind of an
objective function or something or
something like that
choice it really depends on on on the
case
i mean at the end of the day like
there's um i like to separate in my mind
the decisions
decision space versus the objective
space um
what i described here is with um
decision space that is quite discreet
um and an objective space that's
discrete but you can
but it is possible to uh look at like
contin
like break down a continuous function
sorry continuous
solutions and and just sorry discretize
them
um so i think that's done as well but
most of my experience has been in
the street space yeah
okay and maybe one last question um
so um
the examples you saw is with a few um
a few dimensions of a few so two
objectives basically
but you're generalizing it towards
multiple objectives
but so what's your experience in um
i can imagine it's it's inconvenient to
have too many objectives right because
then you get a super complex burrito
from that you is really hard to
interpret
uh that's your experience in having
many objectives yeah well um
i mean it's on the one hand it's i mean
there's two challenges first is the
um cursive dimensionality in which
things become too sparse so you want to
keep it um
i i admit that i haven't looked beyond
like i know like
eight objectives or something like that
i think i i kept it to about eight
um and the way to visualize it to myself
i look at like just 2d plots
of of the combinations um
just just to get a feel for what's going
on if there are more more regions of
interest or not um but yeah that that's
that's
that's a challenge so you just make a
bunch of 2d plots yeah
each of them against each other or yeah
and then you can see that with where
your main traders are and objective
functions
yeah but but also yeah those visuals are
useful yeah those visuals are useful
because then you can identify parameters
that kind of agree with each other
and then you can choose one of the other
and reduce your space to make it more
simple for example
or because they kind of agree you can
actually turn
those two into a single heuristic or
something like that
um but the important thing is the ones
that are that clearly conflict and
you know have no correlation between
them then
um that then yeah you want to be
agnostic of any relationship between
them
and then yes so so i think looking at
correlations actually would be a good
idea
uh if you do that up front before you
that might
save you time in your search if you
examine the correlations
also if you need to ask your users or
stakeholders like okay you need to
make some decisions on uh you can pick
all the objectives right
yeah then you can search through them
and the animation that you show
there's like got some density in the top
right corner well
then you have quite good alternatives
for both objectives right
so you kind of want to filter down
between when it looks more like this one
that you see here
because that's where decisions need to
be made which one is more important
i guess yeah my experience with most
most stakeholders all they want
is like a list that they can just go
through and
it's nice to know um if they want to
take agency on why the decision was made
and that's great then
you it's the job of the analyst to come
up with meaningful visuals for them
that's always a challenge and
fun challenge i always find but a lot of
times my experience with stakeholders is
just give me a list
i trust your decisions and um but
sometimes i admit that you know i have
to consult them because of the main
expert of wichita go but sometimes they
don't know themselves and they leave it
to me to make the decision